[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster i'm konstantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
guests our brilliant guest this week is
a wonderful comedian Andrew Lawrence
welcome to trigonometry oh thanks for
having me on yeah I should be a guardian
journalist just to give you one good
review so anyway one decent comedy
journalist yes it'll be a long time
before that happens them right that
one's for you Steven yes no
what's-his-face
Bennet Ryan Brian what we wanted to talk
to you about is the sense I get from you
there's you you want things to be fair
and meritocratic well this is what's
wrong your career you felt like that
wasn't happening and there was a
particular moment I think where all that
came to a head about that I think
yeah they you can get to certain places
there is there was an element of
meritocracy to it
no it's certainly very naive and it is
very naive to think that you know it's a
business and I didn't think it would
work or merit but that's all I had well
if I work hard if I work hard I'll get
there if I'm working harder than
everyone else and I'm better than
everyone else more turns than their last
getting a bigger reaction or more laughs
on the night and everyone else which is
the only way aged these things then then
I'll make some sort of progress and the
only progress I really wanted to make
was to have some sort of quality of life
financially and do my own tour intros I
wanted to I wanted to play to my own
audiences in in sort of art center
venues and I achieved that and I still
do that and then so I achieved what I
wanted to do that
became disillusioned because I thought
it was a more kind of morally that it
was a better industry than it was and
more though there were values there
because it certainly there is a face to
the comedy industry there is a front to
it the especially now that there's
there's something ethical going on these
are good people which is not the cases
it's like many other businesses there's
a lot of nastiness a lot of corruption
going on and you expect that and you
just try Bessy work hard and you see
what happens but you know I certainly
got disillusioned but um I did a show in
in 2000 and summer of 2014 at the end of
Fringe bewitched I might I've them quiet
company with the big powerful agents
that I've been signing with and I was I
was now with a smaller small independent
agents because I knew I'd sort of I'd
sort of been tuned up a smile I knew I'd
had my I'd had my run I've had my run
and now that I'm moving on so leaving me
behind and it was someone who other
people's turn it was the next it was the
next thing was coming for him people
were bored of me now and you know that
was all right as long as I was making a
living so I'm the smaller more
independent agent I went up to a number
with them really really good at him
really well-received show predominantly
kind of five stars and four stars and
then a few a few quite nasty reviews
towards the end of the vessel quite
politically the show there was called
reasons to kill yourself and and the
first them 40 probably the first 40 45
minutes the shows was just a gag gagg
about about being quite miserable and
quite depressed naturally as a person
and then about death as well and then I
never would have figured
then the last 15 minutes and the show
was I am I stopped in the Gag Gag Gag
every 20 seconds and that became a lot a
longer form bit for the last 15 minutes
which allowed me to kind of talk about
my experience in stand-up comedy and how
I've been quite naive and I've given a
lot more of myself and sacrificed a lot
more than I should have thinking that
thinking that there was the element of
merit would see me through and they
hadn't worked out
and that's um you know a side effect of
that was the relationship I'd been in
with someone I'd lived with her for nine
years and she had also started out in
comedy the same time as me and she'd won
a channel for writing competition and
they've done nothing for nothing and
she'd had nine years of misery and and
no income
nothing and and it's you know ruined
their life really because you know this
this guy running channel for for well
I'm this new comedy wiring initiative
and it's a national thing we'll do it
but then we will just once it's done
he'll be good for me and be good for my
career cuz that I've done this thing but
everything just won't care about them
will brush them under the carpet but so
that relationship came to an end and I
was I was sort of angry for her and I
always um I was quite so feeling sorry
for myself and it was it it was a
powerful show I think it was very very
funny for those 40 40 45 minutes and
then I last 10 15 I thought I caught us
I was saying what I wanted to say but
also what I felt a lot of other comics
and a lot of people coming into the
industry
I wanted them to hear before they made
the
voices and commitments that though I had
made a space say it went very well and I
the enema freeze nothing came of it
because it was because I was done I've
had my run and it didn't matter how well
I did up there I was sort of you know I
was yesterday's news and I've been
cheered up and that's fine because I'm
still doing when I was still on tour and
October that year I posted and I was
sort of starting to post more on
Facebook and Twitter and then I had
previously you can see where this is
forum because so many of the people come
to see me of course they follow me on
social media whatever the [ __ ] or
whatever it is 20,000 and Twitter or
whatever
no no but there's a lot of people that
buy tickets and try to be funny all the
time and try and engage with those
people on on social media and that's
what I was doing all the time and and
one post that I put on on Facebook got
picked up by by certain people within
the comedy industry some quite
successful people within the comedy
industry who have really pissed off and
what I'd said and some of them and and
decided they were going to go on a bit
of a run with it and what did you Sandra
because I wasn't as I said I wasn't a
comic at the time so I didn't although
well they would there were there were
three strands to it the first I think um
it was about how panel shows they've
been to many cheap and easy jokes about
them you kept on panel shows and that I
felt like it was out of touch I felt
like this was 2014 before we'd have a
girlfriend the mom makes it I felt like
it was out of touch I felt that this is
why I put in the post that the actually
UK were resonating with a lot of people
and I think comedians were a little bit
sir in a bubble
and they added that's a mild
understatement
they were survey lien acing people by
not but not realizing realizing that and
then I said that people also people were
getting on those panel shows not based
on merit but based on fact they were
ticking boxes equality and diversity
boxes which is true and remains true
it's it's a primary it's a primary
reason for people being booked for a
comedy panel shows and for stand-up
shows on the BBC and on channel 4 and
the third strand of the post was that
some following on from saying a lot of
people resonated with you kid because a
lot of people were quite upset about in
recent years they've been a math
uncontrolled level of immigration we
should learn enormous strain on public
services on housing and it had been a
cynical thing it been something that had
been done to push a lot of unskilled
labor into the into the job market so
wages for the poorest lowest pay people
could be kept artificially low because
there was such a demand those jobs and
zero hours contracts could be rolled out
and those are the three strengths of the
post but of course within that there's a
lot within that that you can use if you
want to if you want to go for someone if
you want to attack someone there's a lot
in there you can use to say all your
this your that this is this is you know
this is you you're saying that but
that's but what you mean is this and and
this was why at the start of where that
became a regular occurrence on social
media on Facebook and Twitter that
there'd be these sort of mass kind of
them pylons where where people would go
for
someone who would expressed a viewpoint
that they didn't agree with and and sort
of manipulate what they had said out of
all proportion and and try to smear and
discredit them and it became I think
that was at the start of that happened
so many so many people there's a shock
enormous shock in comedy because it was
right at the stop well you kind of got
cancelled before that was like the cool
thing yeah I think you're a trailblazer
I don't it it's difficult because to
know the extent and there is an extent
to which I was counseled there is an
extent to which after I put that post up
it affected me work-wise definitely I
lost a lot of work because of that post
yeah I got a lot of work because of that
at the same time I can't say that the I
don't think it cost me any sort of let's
say TV work or further work I had a
sitcom in development I carried out and
went through with the BBC ready for but
I don't think it cost me any working
broadcasting because the parameters have
changed there and they wanted people
there was an equality and diversity
agenda rightly or wrongly I don't care
well that's how it is they wanted people
who were taking certain boxes and
ability comedic ability was secondary to
that to that political agenda and so I
was out of the door already because of
that so putting that post up you know
Wilson could not affect that it
certainly I was just out and tall at
that point I wasn't here I wasn't doing
Club gigs because I didn't need to I was
just touring but there was certainly
venues that wouldn't book me there have
booked me a lot in the past regardless
the fact they hadn't seen the show that
I was doing so you got put in a box
basically yeah they based on that
yeah Facebook post on what they'd read
about it's somewhere when they read
about it was someone else's Twitter feed
or read about it in an online blog or
something based on that they decided
they didn't want to let me ask you
something because are you happy with the
way that you phrased what you said
they're not yes I remember when we had
Simon Evans on your show great comedian
one of the things he said there's a lot
of people in the comedy industry agreed
with you mm-hmm
and he did yeah but the way you phrased
some of the of the points that you made
which yeah my opinion a perfectly
legitimate valid points for someone to
have weather I personally agree with her
or not she yeah the way he said that he
felt the way you phrased some of that
something about with female comedians
pretending to be comedians or something
I don't know if that's the right quote
but like you felt that he was much more
difficult for people to defend you oh
it's very he's very loaded but that was
where the humor was in there and don't
forget the only reason the reason why I
was putting these posts up on Facebook
and on Twitter was to try and entertain
and amuse the audience my audience of
ticket buyers had come to see my show so
that's who it was for
it's not me phoning up comedians and
radiant's or TV production companies or
sending them an email or you're a bit
[ __ ] woman they saw it because it's yeah
I want to look at the pages ups if
someone I'll shared it someone share
them and which is fine but you know it
wasn't intended for them and there's no
no reason why they should have bothered
it with it anyway they might have looked
inside I don't agree with that and moved
on but they didn't want to do that they
wanted to do more than that and the
expression I used to think very
different 2014 I said the comics have
been before comedy show is based on
their gender ethnicity sexual
orientation so I'm and I think I talked
I said
there were women posing as comedians on
panel shows which there were and there
were no comedy panel shows with
comedians and there were women who were
comedians on there have been who are
open spots essentially who were doing
open spots or middle spots at gigs who
had been fast-tracked well things
haven't changed for me that is hot way
of putting it
well I'm afraid you are if you're an
open spot or a middle spot he's just
starting to be paid at gigs and you have
been fast-tracked in for live at the
Apollo which was what was to mock the
week which was what was happening then
because they wanted female comedian if
that's who you were then then you were
still learning your craft you were
posing as a comedian you weren't there
yet you know getting there butter and
it's certainly harsh phrase but if
you're reading it as someone who comes
to see go see comedy buys tickets for an
aunt enormous comedy show it it's the
harshness of the phrase is quite funny
because the very fact that I've written
the post at all is he's risking it back
then he's even risking because it's
flies in the face so much of what the
mentality and the ethos of the comedy
comedy industry was in these wars back
then is now it was so there's such a
sort of biting my hand that feeds you
exercise that's where the humor was the
audacity and the cheek of doing that
that's why it was funny
which is his calling tough to explain it
his calling to have to explain because
people got that but and then people
choose chose to ignore that as well and
when Simon Evans says oh I didn't agree
why it says that's not my dessert no he
said I didn't agree with a phrase that
he's missing the fact that it wasn't
intended for him and it wasn't intended
for the comedy industry why on earth
would I bother wasting my time putting a
post on our social media
for any other anyone else than the
people who who buy tickets to see my my
shows and also it's not as if I was the
first person the first comics to
criticize and take take the piss out of
Mock the Week I think a lot of people
have been saying it was bad for a very
long time and continue to say it's bad
online a lot of comics so you put the
post up
yeah you saw the reaction there must
have been a bit of you Andrew there must
have for [ __ ] sake what have I done
here
do you regret putting that poster I felt
no I don't well if I didn't yeah I
wouldn't have put it up before I'd known
the reaction he's still up there now so
the contents of it I'm happy with and I
regret a reaction if I knew the reaction
I wouldn't have put it up but at that
point I felt detached from the comedy
industry anyway at that point because
all I was doing was going and and this
was the extent of my job was I was going
to arts centre venues I didn't have a
support I didn't have a tour manager or
anything like that I go to my Art Centre
venues I meet the technician and we work
out the lights and the sound and I do my
show you and I go home so it was
detached from the whole comedy industry
and had been for probably probably a
year or more because I wasn't really
seeing other comedians socially or other
or geeks I wasn't doing TV or radio
really at that point I was just doing
those tour dates so and these people who
suddenly cut comics who were suddenly
leaving comments or messaging me on
social media many of whom I'd never met
before in my life
and some that I had way talking to me
now I haven't talked to you in years you
know feel free come and chat to me any
time on social media but I I don't know
I do you're even following me or looking
at my posts and so it was odd and my
reaction was well just just leave it I'm
not really
I thought like I wasn't part of I felt
like I was apart from it that it had
never been my politics that the politics
of the company and I don't really I
don't know what what I am oh it changes
all the time politically or I'm quite um
I don't some quite you know without
sounding poncey I'm quite no holistic I
don't really I struggled to find any
real sort of meaning or have any real
fixed views constantly you know at
different times I think you know I think
different things but I'm not really cuz
I just want to see the world burn and
I'm just not really committed to
everything I mean I'm not really which
is nihilism
I'd never I'd always felt sort of out
sorry that in in the stand-up industry
to that degree in green rooms in
dressing rooms and on TV things I felt
like an outsider but then he Stefan
saying if it was like you're I'm you
know you feel this is it I know where
I'm what I'm doing and this is and this
is perfect I don't want to do anything
else but that I know what my policy
sorry I don't have any fixed politics
all I knew was I wasn't that sort of
sanctimonious self-righteous sort of
faux liberal thing that has existed in
comedy long before any of us died but I
felt like I could do it anyway I was
able to I was allowed to do stand-up
comedy I didn't have to be that thing
but maybe I did maybe you do have to be
there thing but so I but it was very
much marketed answer as when it happened
and as in Andrew Lawrence has now gone
right-wing and Lawrence is now turned to
the dark side
well I think that that was it was is one
particular journalist at a time picked
up on it specifically which was a guy
called Steve Bennett who runs a comedy
website called shorter one and and when
I put this Facebook post
I think there were three articles about
me on there on the home page or the
website very unusual um well no you know
I wasn't well even though the peak of
the work I was doing ago I still
occasionally get recognized once every
probably where once every couple of
weeks or so you're that comic but and
then you might happen every far as out
and about maybe once every three days or
something but you know we're a Herald so
in many ways I hated all that I wasn't
well known and so there was no that
there was something extra no the fact
that he picked up on it thought I'm
gonna Rumble this and I'm sure he was
getting hits it must have been the it
was he was getting a lot of hits on his
website did the same thing with me when
I turned out and that contract he did
exactly the same thing and there was no
but what really happened with you it
seems to me is there you tread on a
landmine which maybe you weren't even
aware of at the time which is we all
know and even the people who had
advocate for the diversity thing they
know what they're doing which is they're
promoting people who who are not and and
I don't say this is a criticism of them
because here it is not their fault but
there are people who are being pushed
because of you as you say they take a
certain box and you just seem to me like
you tread on that land mine because
maybe you hadn't realized how toxic an
issue was because you were really saying
then Perez naked when no one wanted to
hear that I don't you know I don't even
mind it I don't even mind I don't mind
people get opportunities for that reason
what I want people to do is admit there
is happening yeah because there's other
people who aren't getting opportunities
because of this political decorator this
political agenda so if you're that
person who's got this opportunity
because you've ticked that box at least
had the humility to to acknowledge that
and know that and actually
some some comedians due to great comedic
effect you know I think him wanna show
anger Nathan who who I love I said I
think he's a great comic and he's a nice
guy
he went on I saw him go on a few shows
and he'd opened why-why-why by saying
don't worry guys doesn't matter whether
I'm funny on my knee at siccar call us
your diversity box or something that I
thought was very funny but he also knows
this truth as well and he he knows that
and he's saying and I respect that and
and also I've seen I think I saw at
least he's like I've seen how the other
comics turb I'm not going to give them
credit for doing it because he's the
first dose order so I have respect for
that and I think I'm a real believer in
that sir and that's some popular
expression stay humble or be humbled and
I just want people to middays going on
as something because it isn't it's all a
little bit yes and you know and then we
see people getting promoted and we're on
hang on I just you're not that good I've
seen you struggle you touch some faux
liberalism which I find really really
interesting within the comedy industry
and that everyone pretends to be liberal
everyone pretends to be woke why have we
got this pressure when really comedians
are always to read full people yeah well
there's it's it's some you only think
that because you work with me I think
it's it's another thing isn't it to want
to devote your life to go step on stage
and trying to make strangers laugh and I
don't think it I think a lot of the time
it doesn't come from a good place
yeah it's very difficult the whole the
sanctimony the the self-righteousness
that the the faux liberalism the the the
posturing you think is this knowingly
deceitful and they knowingly
putting on this front or is this sort of
is it a sort of Massey's theories there
a car is it a cult you know I mean it
because I like the lights if you've got
a little bit of faith in humanity you
think I don't want to think that it it's
a deceit they're doing it because they
think it would help their career I don't
want to think that I want to think it's
because it's it's got into their head
because it doesn't have to be that's
easy because like I was talking to
somebody at a comedy club the other day
and he was saying to me I really like
the way you talk about politics cuz I
can't do it and I don't know that what
do you mean you can't do it anyone well
I'm just a straight white guy born
British therefore if I start talking
about my opinions I'm going to get
destroyed there's also just an element
of like survival instinct for some
people generally I mean it's not like
fear yeah well it's not like they've sat
down and got all what's the best way to
advance my career they maybe just don't
want to get crushed if you got if you're
a good comic you go for what's difficult
yes what's the one thing people what's
the one thing where there's jeopardy and
me making jokes about it because if you
get it right there's a risk the risk
wall thing is if you tackle that subject
that could ruin you and you get it right
there actually the whole room explodes
laughs the people double over laughter
if you get it wrong ten years ago you
probably Dyson RS to the gig dimmer you
start again and the next gig you get on
this now could be could be the whole
career over it could be as a comedian so
the risk world is much greater but there
is a positive to that in as much as it
is quite quite an exciting time to watch
those comics say those things and take
those risks where you think this can
ruin you but you're getting it right and
it's hilarious because if those comics
said the same thing ten years ago
if Patrice O'Neal who's maybe probably
arguably the best of all time one of the
best of all time Patrice O'Neal said the
things he said whatever it was I don't
know why can't I harass you well yeah if
he's whatever whatever he the things he
said on stage are we gonna say 15 years
ago he said them then and they offer and
he just brilliant if he said them now
and get all go away with it which he
would imagine how much funnier because
of the Jeopardy and the joy they don't
give you think you can you can do it
it's like the Chappelle special or Ricky
Gervais exactly what you were crying out
watching like those Chappelle specials
in recent years exciting he's going to
the Bilbo as well
and Andrew Schultz as well Andrew
Schultz in this country wouldn't would
not if he was starting out wouldn't get
a gig he'd be hippie he'd be blacklisted
everywhere he would be blacklisted he
would not he would not play anywhere I
think okay so that's a great point so
he'd be but why do you think we have
this urge to blacklist people is it I
said of a word and I blow this might be
all you know all sort of suddenly you
know shun or whatever else all honest
people I'm having the wrong opinion or
the wrong type of comment you see it's
all done very carefully there's nothing
it so much of it isn't overt but you see
Alistair Williams talk about how I can't
play the clubs the clubs he used to book
me won't book me and my career's over
because I put this video but breaks it
this was a funny funny video you should
watch if you haven't Alastair Williams
brexit Burger King's very funny video
and he says I put this video up and now
my career is finished comedy career is
finished and I'm sure a lot of people
looking at I think really he yeah he
sure I'm not I think you're playing up
to this a little bit but I know because
I've been there that actually there are
clubs there are clubs that the
book him now and for him the difference
between those clubs that won't book him
that were booking him who are not
booking him now is the difference
between making a living and not so by
putting that video up and these clubs
not booking him anymore
he's not able to make a living from
stand-up potentially which means he
can't focus on on what he's doing
full-time he's got to find some other
source of income and it's very very
damaging to him as a comedian in
developing going to do gigs and writing
and coming up with new material because
now he's got a lot of money worries
about how he's going to pay his bills
when actually his diary should be for
every weekend should be fullness diary
because he's a good comic and he he
delivers and he's reliable and he's he's
not he's not controversial actually he's
not you know you can you can look at
some of the stuff he posts online I
think he's controversial but he puts him
in a club anywhere on a weekend and
he'll he'll deliver and he's a very
reliable act so people should book him
and I know he's he's not lying there are
clubs that because they you know when I
touring venues some of them stop looking
me and even this time around what's all
this time around I send him a copy from
the blurb for the show to promote the
show that they put on their website
whatever it is a hundred words or
something and based on that not a word
of the show they haven't seen the show
don't even know what the show is before
or what the content of the show is
before they booked in to venues on this
short show on this tour booked my
showing
contracts all done got the copy for the
show so we're not we're not doing this
so they had to pay me a cancellation fee
because they won't cancel the show it's
just fine I don't have to make the
journey on your notoriety money it's the
I but then I came to do playing less and
less touring menu so I thought I'm gonna
stay sharp I'll go back and do the clubs
but then when I went about to try and
clubs clubs the ides headline for years
and years regularly suddenly I couldn't
wouldn't talk to me wouldn't wouldn't
return my mouth my phone calls nothing
they won't talk to me
and frozen out bye-bye boy by some
Booker's who knows that if they put me
on a bill I've got the TV credits also
the tickets they know I'll deliver
because I have dinner so long I know I'm
not particularly
I'm not controversial they know that and
this is the thing I'm not even the
Facebook place I'd never put anything on
social media has got me suspended all or
any kind of banned from social media
never not once I wish we could say that
there's this this false impression out
there of me of being a controversial
comedian which has been generated by
this journalistic input at the time I
put that Facebook post up
chortle website steve bennett going runs
had put three articles about me on the
on the home page of his website which is
unusual because no one knew who I was
really I'm not not well-known and he
sort of it was obviously getting it's
from for him
probably for Domini from people within
the comedy industry so so he ran with it
and made a lot more of it
then there was made in something a lot
more controversial than it was and then
I think the independent as well at the
time which was still a newspaper rather
than just an online blog publishing some
stuff about me as well so I thought all
this would get people clicking online
which was quite far removed from
anything that I'd put I put up on social
media but they wonder the clicks for
advertising or
speaking of magnetizing before Francis
asked our last question because we're
out of time you're about to go on tour
at the time this comes out you may
already be on tour which is called Pale
Male and stale here a title pal may
understand so where can people get
tickets for that I'm sure you'll be at
least as funny as this interview if not
it's not more yeah I saved all my best
stuff how do people get tickets website
Andrew Lawrence comedy doc who don't you
K and it's just a staggered tour yes if
you feel like coming along is a very
very very funny comedian though there
was one question I wanted to ask which
before we wrapped up and I kept trying
hard skin and came down away sure the
thing I loved about your comedy I was a
still I'm a massive fan but when I first
as an open spot on one of my favorite
comedians genuinely and the reason was
is because you wouldn't have with your
jokes I would describe as a beautiful
savagery to the way you're right yeah
and I look at Mock the week and I look
at a lot of these you know satirical
panel shows old people on TV and it's
[ __ ] boring comedy to me should be
about saying the truth however
unpleasant it may be and just hittin
that bull's eye yeah and that's what
audiences that's what deep down we go
and see comedians that's why we we
worship the prize of Patrice O'Neal's
you Bill Hicks is you know you're Joan
Rivers people who come out why has it
become so boring well you know I think
it was the the sort of comedians you're
talking about from a predominantly
American comics and I think there's a
lot more room you can do in America as a
stand-up I think for a lot of years not
anymore but when I started out probably
until probably until four or five years
ago the BBC was was was what you what
you aim for and to get to go on and they
had to you have to walk down down what
you do and I did that
that's today as well and then because
you know want some money
you don't want to live in a dump and you
know he's got family you got kids to
support and mortgages to pay and nursery
fees you love stand-up but you gotta
find the money from somewhere and if
you're looking the further you go away
from stand up to look for alternative
streams of income the worst you get
stand up because you need to be giving
it your full focuses you can't do it
half-assed it's you have to give it
everything absolutely everything to be
good at it to be really good at it you
have to there can't be anything else I
think Andrew so before we let you go the
last question we always ask is what is
the one question that no one's talking
about the one issue that no one's
talking about but we should be talking
about yeah you know why it's difficult
because it's all out there isn't it it's
all out there somewhere there's too much
talking there's too much talking I think
him
alright that's it we're shutting down
and the conversation hashtag no debate I
think then there needs to be a more
discussion about some social media and
and how its regulated or not regulated
as the case may be and about them I
think and a lot more exploration of its
impact on people's and people's lives I
think we're just scratching the surface
of that I think things that Facebook and
Twitter Instagram and now having a
profound impact on a lot of people's
lives and I think um I think there has
to be I think has to be some
acknowledgement of that first of all but
I think there has to be a lot of
discussion about that not enough
discussion about that I think takes
place it's a great great honor and it's
actually very you know it's very
prescient because as a former teacher
I've seen the effect you know
children completely addicted to
smartphones all the rest of it being
right till 2:00 in the morning 10 11
year olds but thank you very much for
coming on the show Andrew people want to
find you on social media ironically
enough where can they do that
Andrew Lawrence on Twitter I guess I
love the way you had to think your own
name yeah by the way well done and
getting the factory or former teacher
into yet yeah absolutely good stuff
yep as always to make sure you follow
and you check my very very funny
stand-up make sure you go see him on
tour really really great comic be
problematic deeply problematic male and
as always follow us at trigger pod you
to YouTube Facebook Twitter etc and
we'll see you in a week time with
another Berlin episode take care see you
next week guys thanks for watching guys
as always subscribe to the youtube
channel click the bell button next to
subscribe button so you get notified
when a video comes out and follow us on
all the social media at trigger pop and
also leave us a nice review on iTunes
and spread the word